[Music]
okay i was expecting to roast all these
drinks and be like a
like a snob but like i haven't had a bad
drink yet
[Music]
hi what's up my name is chris and i
worked as a barista
at voltaire in san jose and people
always ask baristas have you ever served
a celebrity
i haven't but i see a lot of people
leaking celebrity orders online
and i thought i'd try to make some of
them at home and see if they're any good
i know ariana grande had that one coffee
line in that one song that was
everywhere last year
apparently now she's like a starbucks
ambassador and she has her own secret
menu drink called the ariana grande
frappuccino
doesn't make that much sense because
she's vegan but it does sound really
good
it's gonna start off with a vanilla bean
frappuccino which apparently doesn't
have coffee in it so i'm gonna use
vanilla bean ice cream with milk and
ice and i'm gonna add in raspberry syrup
i couldn't find that syrup anywhere so i
just use raspberry preserves
and turn it into a syrup on the stove by
adding water and a little bit more sugar
i'm surprised the raspberry jam into
syrup thing turned out as well as it did
then we got chocolate chips chocolate
syrup and i'm gonna mix that in and
blend it all
then obviously gotta serve it in a clear
glass top it with whipped cream and a
little bit of caramel
okay yeah yeah that's that's really good
but i don't know what else i was
expecting
because it's literally just an icy
milkshake which is always going to be
good
so it definitely would have been better
if i used full fat ice cream
and milk that's probably where the
raspberry comes into play because it's a
little bit acidic and acid
generally tends to cut through fats
that's why people use like lemon juice
vinegar lime whenever they make like
really fatty meats
this is coming out of nowhere but i feel
like a pinch of salt you know like
salted caramel
i don't know why that would make it
better now charlie d emilio recently did
a partnership with
duncan on a drink called the charlie i'm
gonna taste test this recipe using the
actual
dunkin cold brew packets and i'm just
gonna follow the instructions that they
give on the box
i'm gonna measure out all of my water
just to make sure i'm not messing this
up
i think four cups is like 950
milliliters or something like that
and i'm gonna saran wrap the top of my
container and put it in the fridge
overnight
it's been about 12 hours and i took the
cold brew out and
made the charlie right over here it's
just cold brew with milk
and caramel i have no clue what a
caramel pump is
so i just went with three tablespoons
it's supposed to be three pumps
so i'm gonna taste test the pure cold
brew on its own just because i don't
wanna do dunkin dirty like that i don't
to mess up the recipe
and then like not like it
okay i kind of messed up because i got
donuts last night so my mouth is already
really clammy and sticky
so the caramel definitely doesn't help
that much okay so a few things to note
one as expected it is a super dark
really low acidity kind of bitter roast
and that makes a lot of sense because
they probably expect people to drink it
with milk
and this kind of a coffee bean holds
itself up to milk really well
and it has a really light body in the
sense that the mouth feel in your mouth
feels physically like water but it is
super strong i know the whole flavor
notes thing is super pretentious but
i'm not getting anything specific in
here maybe
chocolaty nutty kind of stuff no
fruitiness
or tartness or bright sweetness in the
coffee itself
and that makes a lot of sense because
they're probably trying to appeal to as
many people as possible by using a
really balanced blend
and it tastes exactly like you would
expect traditional
coffee to taste like i used to think
that i would never
ever drink coffee black but that's just
because i was using really dark roasts
from large commercial brands
they really try to sell you on that
saying that it's stronger but you can
get a stronger flavor
in lighter or medium roast just by the
way that you brew it
and dark roast tend to hide
inconsistencies and imperfections in
beans but yeah i really like this
back to ariana grande she partnered with
starbucks on another drink
called the cloud macchiato it looks cool
because it has this really fluffy foam
that they call
cloudfoam and i think we can replicate
that by using
icing sugar and powdered egg whites
which i got in the form of meringue
powder
i got some of the starbucks espresso
beans but i don't have an espresso
machine so
i try to make something that's just
close enough
by dialing it in on a mocha pot and no
it's technically
not espresso like it doesn't have enough
pressure so you don't end up with that
crema on top
but like come on i tasted it before
putting in the milk and it's close
enough
like relax i'll take it off the stove
once it starts bubbling and i'll run it
under cold water to stop the extraction
it should give me about 45 to 50 grams
or so
and then i got to make the foam i don't
have an electric mixer so we're gonna
have to whip this one by hand
which gives me really bad flashbacks to
dow gonna coffee
so i brought an elbow brace just in case
of tendonitis
yeah whipping anything by hand takes
about like 20 years or so
um it's about the journey not the
destination or something like that
put some milk and then get a spoon and
make it look all nice
look at that and then they make this
waffle thing with the caramel
here we have it right here all of the
normal sized cups were in the dishwasher
but this is actually closer to the
traditional
macchiato size the italian macchiato is
just two shots of espresso
with a tiny little dollop of foamy milk
on top this is not the starbucks
macchiato because they do it like
backwards theirs is like a
latte macchiato but the typical cafe
macchiato or espresso macchiato is like
barely any milk and it's like
that small so let's go ahead and try it
okay i was expecting to roast all these
drinks and be like a
like a snob but like i haven't had a bad
drink yet um but the caramel on top is
actually is it caramel or caramel
the caramel caramel the caramel's a nice
touch i feel like all starbucks drinks
are kind of the same thing it's just
like
vaguely milky coffee kind of flavor with
some hit
of sweetness yeah the foam barely tastes
like anything
so i try to find other interesting
coffee orders everyone else just gets
soy lattes but in an interview
khloe kardashian said that she gets a
venti
seven pump no water chai latte first of
all chai
is just tea so it has to have water
second how is it a pump what i think
they mean is that they just brew chai
tea and then
reduce it down to like a concentrate
that they use as a syrup and then when
they serve it they just cut it with
water to make it back into tea and then
make the latte so chloe probably just
wants to concentrate with the milk
i saw that starbucks on their website
shows what's in their chai
and i could do that from scratch but
it's kind of similar to this tea bag
that i found at the grocery store
i'm going to use seven bags and then
reduce it down into a syrup with sugar
that's
roughly what seven pumps would be in
volume and then make the latte out of
that let's go ahead and try it
okay that's not bad if i had to pick a
least favorite one it would probably be
this one but
i'm surprised that it's pretty spicy and
it cuts through the milk pretty well
i learned a few things one you can make
a dessert taste fancier just by adding
some kind of
acidic tart fruit even if the dessert
itself
isn't supposed to be acidic or tart i
learned that cold brew packets work
you can just make syrups on the stove
and foam
is exhausting
[Music]